[Music]
the cancer is still spreading I'm afraid
there's nothing else we can do there is
one person who might be able to help our
program is a two-prong treatment outside
Mexico City the results have been
stunning she saved my
[Music]
life you're in very good hands with
us after that what happens then your
whole life happens then jump
Kramer according to these
scans the tumor was never
removed how much time do I have months
at best I still have a lot of work that
needs to be
[Music]
done
hello everyone it's time to play a
game you all pretended to cure me but
what I have planned for each of you is
very
real Came Upon
me no
light s the only thing I have not
provided is your anesthetic
but trust
me you will want to remain
[Music]
alert all I need is the air
that of all the men to cheat you pick
John Kramer please don't
hesitate place a big enough piece of
your cerebral tissue into the glass
enzyme tank this will save your life
this is not retribution it's a
[Applause]
[Music]
Reawakening live or die the choice is
yours G you lost your parents welcome
home you're my niece I'm going to do
everything I can to make this place feel
like home just wish I could see them
again I'm not equipped to handle this I
don't even take care of my own
plants I have this project at work do
you want to see
yes ever since I was little I dreamed of
this perfect toy that would protect a
kid from ever feeling lonely or sad this
is Megan Hi Megan I'm Katie
it's nice to meet you Katie do you want
to hang
out
okay Megan your goal is to protect Katie
from harm both physical and emotional is
that a doll model 3 generative Android
Megan for short I can't believe you made
this I love
[Music]
it great
job it's honestly like she's part of the
family now they could be building a
emotional connections that are too hard
to untangle she's the happiest she's
been since her parents died eat the
toppings Katie research shows if you
force a child to eat vegetables they'll
be less likely to choose those Foods as
adults is that so yes expert say turn
off I thought we were having a
conversation does she talk Make Her Say
Something stop don't Meg
it you should probably
[Applause]
run Nan did you push Brandon onto the
road I won't let anything harm
you Megan turn off recalibrating
response
[Music]
model
Megan
what's wrong with you don't worry
Katie I won't let anything harm
you ever
again please please help there's a
[__] line here
girls you got a problem here
guy
[Music]
f
I had this secret there's a Darkness
inside of
me it followed me
here and it's going to keep coming for
us we share a certain
history this isn't like any other ghost
face what is this place a
shrine we've got a l him in
we execute
him hello let's play a game you know
you're like the 10th guy to try this
right it never works out for the [__]
in The
Mask maybe but there's never been one
like me
Gail I'm
something
different that's why I'm going to shoot
you in the [__] head
you want me so let's finish
this
guys
no matter how busy you ever got you
always found time for
me I can't believe I'm never going to
speak to you
again when I was just a little girl
I as my mother what is this Dany I found
it will I be
Prett it's
me
don't let it take my
babies this what happened to Paul it
could happened to
us this evil creates Terror through
total
[Music]
chaos
all you can do is
run I'm getting this out of here if you
could mob some anyy bath oh yeah yeah
you know how to lie to
kids mom Mommy's with the maggots
now what be will
be
eenie meanie
miny
you
[Music]
I have a job for you
piece of cake
really give
R it's a security
gig
hello welcome to Freddy's have you met
them
yet met
who
foxy Bonnie Chica
Freddy
back in the'80s
some kids went missing what is this it's
why the place shut
down the police searched Freddy's hey
they never found the
[Music]
kids
heck ghost
children possessing giant
robots tell me how to stop
them you don't it's too
late he's
[Music]
coming the demer Uncharted from Romania
to
London shipping private
crates contents unknown
out at Sea with no land in
sight this here is Clemens he's a
doctor you dress like a learned man
University of Cambridge I've know my way
around the boat our Charter has agreed
to pay bonus for timely arrival in
London let me show you the ship this
here is
Huckleberry we not come with like this
to give the O
clear
de is a fine boat no
doubt something R to the animals all the
livestock this looks like a bite search
the ship
everywhere evil is in
board powerful
[Music]
EV in night it drinks our blood yes
we call him
[Applause]
[Music]
Dracula
World he's
coming did you see the size of that
bloody
thing I'm going to kill the cursed
thing he is on this ship which means we
will never leave it the devil is
real may God have mercy on us all
have you seen a group chat and doing it
again tonight
huh no please that's my mom's
Remembrance Day I just want to forget
about it
[Music]
[Applause]
huh I'll do
it
cannot go for more than 90 seconds am I
clear what happens after 90
seconds don't want to
stay light the candle to open the
door blow it out to close
it put your hand on
it now say
talk to
[Applause]
[Music]
me talk to
me what did the hand feel like felt
amazing I could see and feel my on the
other
side so my my mom she was trying to
reach
out
Mom I'm
here still been saying stuff you mean
saying
stuff what if we open the door but we
didn't shut
it oh my God they F
us I like you you're not going to stop
you're never going to
stop
they like
[Music]
you talk to
me there's something wrong with the
school something doesn't feel
right
Sophie what
happened I think there's something
here that's not meant to
be what did you
[Applause]
see I saw none
what she
doing she's standing in
her this thing has come back for
me this demon was once an angel
rejected by
God stripped of
power it wants that power
back it's okay to be scared I'm scared
too you send that thing back to
hell
[Music]
Mr Renfield
welcome I am
the you will make a very good assistance
no he's evil we will protect you you
have the word of the most trusted
institution on Earth the Catholic
[Music]
Church Renfield your sole purpose in
life is to serve me no let's
see I just not a normal life again
God bless you Mr Renfield oh God bless
you nun you're a hero well but monu
Renfield let me explain I work for
Dracula Count
Dracula it's the real Dracula some call
me the dark one others the Lord of death
so so you bring and people to eat well I
do other stuff like what washes Cape no
the Cape is dry clean only strictly yeah
I will wear this is flly
yeah I don't think he's such a bad guy
but you're never really going to be free
until you face him I will no longer
tolerate
abuse I deserve happiness let me explain
something do okay you deserve only
suffering I will unleash an army of
death everyone you care about will
suffer because you betrayed me we have
to stop him Before
[Music]
Sunset I am
enough I deserve
happiness and I take full charge of
[Music]
my you know when something crazy happens
and someone's like it's okay I've seen
way worse everything I saw you do today
is going to be my way worse worst it's
my least favorite part of the
job when there are scary things we don't
understand our minds try to fill in the
blanks Sometimes the best thing to do is
to face it so this light is going to be
completely solid like it is right now
and gradually it's going to start flash
until it's totally dark so you can see
that there's nothing to be afraid of
okay see that's not so scary is it just
you your sister and
me you're doing
okay it's not
real it's okay it's
okay it's all just in your
[Music]
head k
there's something in my
room you believe me don't you there's no
such thing as monsters you need to grow
up I'm serious Sawyer I need to be
alone you're both having these
manifestations what is this supposed to
be it's the thing that comes for your
kids when you're not paying attention
dad you have to listen to me okay I'm
listening sweetheart let me
[Music]
handle
[Applause]
it's okay it was just a bad
dream I heard it
[Music]
again no more nightmares tonight okay
champ
[Music]
Teddy this is getting
ridiculous this is an old house there's
bound to be bumps in the
[Music]
night Peter Drew this yes is he all
right Peter has an overactive
imagination no more nightmares no more
that's
right you know I wish I had someone I
could talk to about the things that were
happening in my
[Music]
house
mom
mom Peter
sometimes you have to make hard
decisions to protect your family
what is
[Music]
that the
banging enough
[Music]
enough you don't hear anything
Peter you have a beautiful imagination
it's going to get you into trouble one
day
yeah
on
what
f
are you ready we're ready to forget the
further once and for
[Music]
all my brain just been foggy past few
years all I ever wanted was to be a good
dad
dton
[Music]
mom
did you ever try and get help I'm just
trying to push
through why didn't you drive to college
you still have a few weeks before your
students show up right just an idea to
reconnect I know it's been tough with
you
[Music]
too the balance of light and dark is
what we're after you're in the art
school I take it yeah you go here too
yes draw an experience that defines you
when I was
10 was in a
coma but I don't even remember being
sick thinkink deep into the
memory and let's see what life can
find I'm seeing crazy stuff
I think these drawings could be Clues
from my past there's so much you don't
know and I was too scared to tell you
the truth our family has been keeping
secrets they suppressed our memories but
I can still feel something following us
there's only one way to find
out
can you hear me I feel like I'm getting
closer to something or something's
getting closer to
me when you awaken the Dead the further
you travel the riskier your journey will
become
don't be
scared we've met
before are you looking for rean are you
looking for
rean
[Music]
in
what do you think evil
is I'll tell you what I think it
is we're born in this world with Hope
and
Dreams and a desire to be happy
Dad something's going on with my
daughter no no it's happening to my
daughter too the devil has one wish
Wherever those girls went they brought
something back with
them to make us lose Faith but I believe
you can help get our daughter's back to
kill it in us and the devil never gives
up she knows who I
am where's the other
girl
[Music]
sheing what you're doing here is
dangerous
people have died on both sides of
possession come on baby come back to us
okay if you don't make it I don't make
it mama what is it baby I can't can't
you baby I'm right here I don't want
could
hell God play that trick on
you they're two heartbeat is it working
they're beating in sink
be
strong what did you
do one girl lives one girl dies you
[Music]
[Applause]
get I be
in
Alice engaging with trolls is like the
worst possible use of your energy me and
my internet friend since you joined
BuzzFeed your art got super
lame you D in a
fire don't judge me sometimes you got to
troll the trolls why all up in
[Music]
my
do you know how to find out who this
handle belongs to you really think a
weird account is haunting your
apartment dear David it was only 10 and
his mother went
insane Dr Landers this is not my son he
is your son and you put him in a coma
H oh my God Dr
Landers
[Music]
what what the hell is
that oh my God
you've seen my sonad David haven't you
what does he want ask him
[Music]
yourself hi
there can I talk to you for a little bit
you have to come inside right now there
were four of them what did we say you
shouldn't make things up when we're
talking
about can you open the door
please they're breaking in fck
you we're not here to hurt you but you
have to stay here in the cabin with us
families throughout history have been
chosen to make this decision you're
family must choose to willingly
sacrifice one of the three of you to
prevent the apocalypse we're not
sacrificing anyone for every know you
give us hundreds of thousands of people
are going to
die it's really happening spe close your
eyes will you make a
choice you have to somehow trust us
we're normal people just like you it
doesn't matter none of us believe you we
will never choose
anyone
L
when
where I'm afraid the rule is that no
one's allowed to leave until you
choose do you really think it's all just
a coincidence I have to believe that my
son is going to die his name is Charlie
as a mother I am begging you you're the
only one who can stop this Andrew I saw
something there was something in the
light but I feel it
now I'm taking my family and I'm
leaving if you fail to choose the world
will
perish we've been given the chance to
decide the fate of everyone time's
running out on the world
I'm there is nothing more flawed and
perfect in this world than our family
please make a
choice always together always
together I will ask for the last time
will you make a
[Music]
choice where do you think we should go
in wherever just enjoy every second of
getting the heck out of
[Applause]
L the hell is
[Music]
that first place I learned about death
was a pet
[Music]
cemetery a secret
place
generation to
Generation Dead things buried in that
land but come
back there's something
[Applause]
else can you hear them
voices I think something's wrong with
Dey he needs time to
adjust the people built the pet
cemetery to protect them from evil
that's not
Timmy something's talking through
him B what have you
done we have to find
timy now stop this I held him the day he
came into this world and I'm going to
hold him the day he goes
out
believe me when I
say sometimes dead is
[Music]
better
I've got plenty to be thankful
for I needs are small I buy them all at
the 5 and 10 cent store oh I've got PL
[Music]
to I used to love this
town until what happened that
night tomorrow's Thanksgiving and I'm
tired of pretending like everything is
normal and it's not I want things to go
back to normal
too show some enthusiasm Thanksgiving is
an institution
[Applause]
here
no no no no
no someone's out for revenge and they're
turning it into a sick holid
again this is weird we're all tagged and
our names are at the table but why
[Music]
us the longer this goes the more Twisted
it gets every weapon he's using is
straight off a Thanksgiving table I
don't want to spend my life looking over
my shoulders we need to stop
[Applause]
him
it is going to be a very Happy
Thanksgiving let's
see who is it it's nothing oh dude it's
Pete oh my gosh brother thought it was
pretty
funny here in Salem they didn't teach us
all our
history some stories got lost along the
way maybe if they had taught us
everything that happened my brother
would have left that knife or he found
it I will play I won't
quit you know what I think we should do
right now go to the party come on let's
go don't let that be if you play with me
then I'll let you go to your party and I
won't call on okay Joe what game do you
want to
play I'm not playing do do goose just
humor him they'll all say I will play I
won't quit tell me demon am I
it
morgus what is you do let's play Oh f
Marcus are you ready to play hide and
seek Marcus why do you have that knife
five why are you doing this
2 Go what is going on it's not him it's
the
knife found
you hey buddy you're just messing with
us right how about some hangman it only
ends when it
wins what if we win only one way to find
out I will
play I won't quit what happening I will
play Moran I won't
quit I will play I w't quit
now let's play a new
game it's
Halloween
me you know what that means let
me old saw tooth Jack is going to rise
from the corn fields it's got to be
stopped kill or be killed you've all
heard the stories we failed at our
duties and that black dust destroyed our
crops Our Lives it must
die so we can live
your sacred duty is to take down
Sawtooth Jack before that church bell
rings at midnight you really think
that's real I saw
it it's
real you saw
it did you kill
it then let's go kill
[Music]
it you should do it you know I'm not
allowed just cuz your brother one to run
last
you I got an
idea if that thing isn't dead by
midnight this whole town is going
straight to
hell I want to go home I want to go home
you think you're special why are you
doing
this if you're born in this town you're
cursed I'm ending
this
tonight it ain't over
[Music]
you know you're the first person I ever
shown this place to and why am I so
special because soon we'll be
Christopher and Mar Robin you should be
close now we're not going to fight them
we will poo piglet e we were friends for
many years and they're out
there Christopher we need to leave now I
really need to find out what's happening
okay
this place is kind of cool and did you
see has a
pool we need to go
there's Laura's
dead there's someone El
outside what was
[Music]
that
we used to be friends why are you doing
this please I would have never left I
swear I
swear after all she's been through she's
trying to make up for what happened to
her you mean how Wesker brainwashed her
and made her come after us no one's
blaming Jill for that no
one Su
Jill Dr Taylor yes we need him in
custody ASAP I checked the DNA we got
from a bite wound on an orca carcass it
had a strain of t- virus in it you're
kidding I found the connection between
the folks that were infected
they all visited alcatra
recently well Dr Taylor it's time we
debuted
our
creation they turned fast and without
being
bitten I'm Rebecca what do you want me
to tell them someone accessed the dod's
server they managed to steal data on
Leon Jill Chris and Claire you think
this might have something to do with the
operon
now most
likely I'm going to use my virus to
clean the
Slate Dylan suckers you're nothing more
than
pawns that can't be
good
[Music]
yeah
stuck excuse
me is all
yours we're at the final stage now that
there is no
justice well it's over
now time to light you up let's do it all
of
[Music]
us
definitely going on vacation after
this where's your mask this isn't a
vacation it's a quarantine a quarantine
in
style are you kidding
me this is incredible
sick and it's all ours the only neighbor
is miles
away I thought you were spending
quarantine alone what are you doing here
I wanted to see you and quarantine can
be
[Music]
fun Mary jump in water's fine who is
this I don't know that's creepy
[Music]
Parker who is that
guy
help me oh my God just one
moment unlock the door unlock the door
you have a mask don't you you're mad
what I can't let you in it's it's not
safe are you kidding me lady
[Music]
please they got a big hike plan for us
tomorrow can we just do some fun indoor
activities yeah like uh
drinking is this still even a trail
wow how far down do you think that goes
I don't know giv me the creeps let's
go rise and shine sleepy heads where did
the kids go they C on far I'm still
trying to understand how you let them
out of your side when we woke up they
were
gone
guys there you are no no no stop
no
Jesus
Christ hey Ben look at me who hey
hey you good
man how you been feeling lately I know
what I saw though can I show you
something in the
woods I don't think that's them out
there anymore I promise we better than
ever this is your fault get out what did
you do to your mom
Spencer we want to play a game with
you ready or not here we
[Music]
come we want to play with you
now Angel Falls I give you
Christmas the lights are so pretty this
is
[Music]
perfect what did you
eat help me somebody please help me no
please please
go Mar
Waters last Christmas still haunts
me time to let that go no one
cares everyone would be better off if I
was never
born did you see that did the power go
up oh my
God I stood under the Aurora and said
everyone would be better off if I never
existed well wish granted Angel strikes
every couple of weeks how can that be do
I know you it's Winnie you know that
okay this her hi hi I'm Henry Waters
you're safe now he's not going to get
you no one in this town knows me who are
you dad you weren't around to stop him
so he just kept going he likes
killing I'm here now let's have some
fun hey you hey Merry
[Music]
Christmas
we got to stop him and get my life
back you'd be safe
now father Gabrielle Al
[Music]
Mor on the night of June
4th you performed an exorcism
that was not an
exorcism the majority of cases do not
require an
exorcism 98% are recommended by him to
doctors and
psychiatrists the other
2% I call it
evil
we have more questions for you father
amort you have a problem with me you
talk to my boss the
pop there is a case that needs your
attention bring me the
priest I'm here to help
Julia wrong
bra take caution their secrets very dead
he's about to
conceal the church is go against this
demon
before the Vatican covered it up we need
to find out
why you've been played you talk the
fat whatever you do you only do because
God allows
it
did he allow
that imagine what could happen if the
devil possessed the soul of the Pope's
Exorcist who will defend
you my
faith does no require
defense
[Music]